my vision should be more community
health centers many many more more HMOs
really control over pharmaceuticals and
the price of pharmaceuticals you know
you could buy you you were able to buy
medicine at thirty or forty or fifty
percent by going to Canada for the same
pills and then they outlawed it they
outlawed it and then Congress passed the
law and was vetoed by the president to
require generics just requiring genetic
medic medication for reimbursement
purposes not a lot more outlaw out
luring it for anything except for
reimbursement could say the American
people in government huge fortune and
I'm very pessimistic about the time it's
going to take to restructure it and the
vested interest and the lobbyists and
and it is so right with doing things the
wrong way and for the wrong reason I
mean we we built we built the first
medical PPO you know I think the first
big nationwide PPO in the country and a
PPO contracts with doctors and hospitals
and labs and surgery centers and and
negotiates discounts with them and then
sells that as a service to health and
welfare funds and insurance companies
the first ten years we Masek for
self-insured union funds and some
employer funds and then after 10 years
we started getting the big insurance
companies
everybody hates everybody hates the
health care system what they like their
own doctor and they can't put the
connection between their own doctor as a
cog in the healthcare system but the
doctor is influenced by the
pharmaceuticals the one of the biggest
lobbyists after defense in America is
the the drug and medical lobby in
America and they're they're 12 in profit
but in getting profit there they're
pushing for a lot of things that are not
medically necessary